hi everyone this is jason riddenberg
from the council of development finance
agencies while michael is getting the
audio going again on his end let me just
say that we are very excited to have you
all online today and be able to bring
you this webcast
today's topic is accessing creative
revenue sources for clean energy
and
we're focused today on some of the
interesting ways that organizations
throughout the country are financing
programs that can be used to
help catalyze clean energy investment so
looking at both energy efficiency as
well as
solar energy and some of the other
different renewable and clean sources
that are out there
we have a great slate of speakers lined
up today we have
christopher jed is going to be speaking
first he's the portfolio energy manager
with the denver housing authority and
annie holzhauser the ceo of greater
cincinnati energy alliance very happy to
have both them
online um michael it looks like maybe
your audio is reconnected yeah i'm back
up and running we had a few a few
technical difficulties there but we are
uh we are back up and running thank you
for stepping in jason it's just you know
an example of the uh the partnership we
got going it's uh yeah that's uh
okay so i think with that um i want to
remind all of our listeners that if you
have any questions for the speakers
please just type them into the
chat window
we'll stop after chris's presentation
to give a bit of time to post some
questions to him and then we'll stop
again after andy's at the end of the
talk
so thanks again and with that i'll hand
it over to chris
all right well good afternoon everyone
and good morning depending where you're
at
um is that is my screen up now am i
i'm i'm assuming everyone can see the uh
the cover screen here
i'm losing audio here
hello we're looking at the the title
screen um i think okay linda's working
on transferring that over we don't have
the title of your screen yet
if you want to go ahead and
be getting your comments get switched
over
okay there we go i think we're good now
um okay so my name is chris jett i'm the
portfolio energy manager at the denver
housing authority and i
oversee all the renewable energy and
energy efficiency upgrades and retrofits
and and
new projects as well
uh briefly a little bit about denver
housing authority
we're located in the city of county of
denver
we have about just over 5000 housing
units that we own and operate
across a portfolio of 30 properties
and those properties consist of row home
garden style apartments
mid-rises as well as single-family homes
and we also administer about 6 700
tenant-based project
eight section vouchers
so those are uh
individual landlords that leverage the
voucher program and within that
portfolio we're pretty progressive with
energy efficiency and renewable energy
we have over seven leed certified
buildings and we just completed an
energy
performance contract that we
self-financed ourselves as well so the
next step for us was to try to figure
out how to
get
pb or solar panels implemented on the
large scale of our portfolio on the
existing units which is difficult
because typically all the new
construction we do we introduce
uh pb
photovoltaic on new construction because
we just rolled into the construction
costs and it's just part of the debt
service
um so the existing portfolio was hard
because of the size it's about 3 600
homes
and this age of them and we'll get into
a little more so so first off why solar
for dha um there's a
a multitude of reasons why but uh
basically
it just aligns with our mission of being
a more sustainable
uh housing authority it provides a large
amount of clean renewable energy
um it provides fixed energy pricing for
a line long term and clearly once you
make the initial investment you know
what your payback is and
the cost of that energy that's going to
cost you
hud is continually rolling out new
financial incentives through different
policies and programs and procedures
they implement one is
the reduced rate incentive
i'm not sure if there's any other public
housing authorities online but
they would um if there's any questions i
can answer that after
um and it aligns with hud's goals with
uh advancing renewable energy across
their larger portfolio
and then last but most importantly why
solar why not wind why not geothermal
we do do a little geothermal but there's
just an abundance of sunlight in denver
as you can see from that map on the
right hand side it's definitely ripe for
um pb installations in relation to other
areas of the country
significantly uh we the panels here
either face south or east to capture
most of the sun
so it was definitely in align with what
we're trying to do and we really want to
set out to retrofit our existing
portfolio
with uh pv panels so
so how do we do that
one like i said it's about 3 700
different homes some are single family
homes some are row homes some
cover a footprint of a couple city
blocks
so it was definitely a challenge and so
we clearly didn't have that capital we
couldn't use the operating subsidy from
hunt for that we could it just wouldn't
have been adequate
you know our capital fund budget was
taxed with other pressing issues in
terms of
reserve replacements and just keeping
the portfolio uh running so we had to
seek outside investment and so we turned
towards a power purchase agreement or
ppa
and basically what this is is it's a
third party private annually it's a
public private partnership with dha
and there's two two parties really right
now one is the third party private
entity and and the other is the site
host so the third party private entity
they are the really ones that that
generate the financing
they they build the panels they own the
panels they operate the panels they
manage the panels they it's it's their
solar panels it just happens to be on
our rooftops and so that leaves us as
the site host and
we had an abundance of rooftops across
the city so it worked out perfect and
so those are the two parties within a
power purchase agreement
um both have different roles and
responsibilities which will and risks
and
rewards as well and we'll get into those
in a little bit
why do we pick a power perks agreement
one is because there wasn't very little
options without any upfront capital we
didn't have a lot of capital this
program was about a 10 million dollar
investment and we just that wouldn't
have existed without it so that was a
clear decision
two power purchase agreements since
we're uh a non-profit we we can't
leverage the investment tax credits and
some other incentives that go along with
this so this makes it a real financial
incentive for an investor because they
can capture all these tax credits um
three the operations of maintenance
we ultimately we're going to own these
panels and we're going to maintain them
but it's nice to have a third party that
doesn't for the first couple years or or
it's it can they can do it for the next
20 years if we want them to but it's a
real nice tool because they they're our
staff is getting uh institutional
knowledge we're getting training and
it's bolstering our staff's
tool belt of
operations and maintenance
and then and lastly why is because like
i mentioned the first priority was
existing properties and there's not a
lot of options for existing properties
so so with all these reasons we we went
down the path of the power purchase
agreement
some some areas we looked at and we had
concern about
is the risks and obviously tax issues
the risks involve that
one is the construction and the project
development just like any
new real estate development
deal you have the closing procedure you
have
a schedule you have to keep in a
multi-family building development you
you have tenants that are moving in so
it's pressing that you complete the
construction process within a certain
time frame
and although you don't have tenants
moving in a lot of the incentives the
tax credits the renewable energy credits
a lot of the
incentives that make this financially
viable are on the timeline too of
completion of construction so it's
certainly critical that you make
yourself aware of all those timelines
and your construction schedule hits
capturing financial incentives is
another risk investment tax critics
renewable energy credits depreciation
all these
are
fairly reliable but they are part of the
cash flow and the performa and if one of
them isn't there then that's an issue
and then moving on to the next bullet
insulation
that's that's a term in the contract
where
you know as the host we need to provide
sunlight to these panels so if a tree
you know it's a 20-year contract so if a
tree doesn't shade a panel now and it
shades a panel later
that's a responsibility of the site
hosts to maintain that
access to the sun and similar to
buildings if we
develop a building on the neighboring
property so that's a risk
changes obviously policy and laws that's
always a risk and then
approvals insurance and other legals
issues
that arise with a deal this size and the
public public-private relationship
and i would certainly encourage and
everyone going down this path to get a
good attorney that has experience in
this as well as a tax accountant that
can help you navigate these issues
tax issues they weren't dha as a housing
authority we couldn't
leverage those we didn't have a tax
appetite so the third party
owner took advantage of all the tax
credits in this case it was a 30
investment tax credit
and they also get to take the
depreciation of the asset as well or the
equipment
so these are some of the things we we
thought through and and we learned
throughout the whole process of what it
took
um and ultimately we we approached it
like we do every project we issued an
rfp
and we and you can see right there that
was the title of the rfp or the the
header of what we were looking for we
were looking for
we we we as a housing who didn't have
the experience behind the project
development for this we have a real
estate department that does a great job
with the buildings and the projects but
actually this power purchase was new to
us so
getting a good team was critical for us
so we set out we sent out an rfp
and we got a couple responses back and
and we we interviewed all firms and we
we selected the best ones which is
moving to this next slide
um
the
to summarize dha's experience on the
right hand side you'll see the
logos of all the firms oak leaf energy
partners they were the project developer
in terms of acting as a developer and
pulling the team together
infiniti
they were ultimately the owners of the
panels and they they still they actually
got
acquired by sun edison last year and
then sun edison actually got acquired by
terraform um i think earlier late last
year so infinity is no longer part of it
but their contracts that's who it
started with and then namaste solar was
the other party we we were involved with
and they are the solar contractors and
they did a great job just the magnitude
and the complexity of the project they
were they brought the
manpower and the panels themselves
on the buildings
so that's kind of the partnership uh a
brief overview of how we did this
um like i said the first step was
issuing rfp and we we issued that we had
a couple respondents and we've added
them and we actually oak leaf partners
was the winning proposal and they
contracted with infinity namaste so
um and then project design that was
tricky because as i mentioned we have
about 3 700 public housing units
in the traditional ppa or more
traditional ppa there's a large solar
field or solar farm or community solar
of some sort where there's not a
multitude of different sites it's one or
two large sites for two and a half megs
this was all individual homes and
rooftops so
the project design took some time
because we had to we started with google
earth and picked out the rooftops that
had the most sunlight didn't have trees
in our buildings and then we went out to
drive those sites and this was all done
by
the project team itself so
the team really did a great job pulling
it together and making it um come
through with the project design
ultimately we found the goal was to find
about 2.5 megawatts worth of
panels across the portfolio so it was
that equated about 660 roofs of solar
so once the project was designed then
the project we went through the
financing stage which again oak leaf
uh partners in infinii really pulled
together strong
the project was financed with energy
bonds
and it was it was kind of a turnkey
program with oakley so it was really it
really worked out well
once financing was secure we did the
construction there was there was a
couple issues with construction because
we had to replace some roofs any roofs
that were of a certain agent needed
replacing we went ahead and did that
beforehand
um as well as we had to make some
structural issues just structural
modifications to some of the rooftops as
well so there was
it was more than just putting solar
panels on the roofs and then and now
we're in the operations and maintenance
phase which is where
namaste uh well terraform right now is
the owner of the panels now and they
they contract with namaste who's
the local resource for solar operations
maintenance so it's
it's in this operations and maintenance
stage is about a well not about it's a
20-year contract and we do have some
options to
to buy them out early so that's kind of
the process what we how we did it and
how we financed it a little overview on
the dha our ours itself it's about 10
million dollars worth of solar panels
and again that was
all for existing homes single-family
multi-family homes you can see in that
picture that's a good example of a row
home community
just um outside of denver
and
that's a perfect example we did that all
over the city and county denver a total
about two and a half megawatts oddly
enough it was 660 homes worth of solar
it's the term is for 20 years and it's a
fixed uh price that escalates but we do
have the option to buy them out after
six years or we can buy them out
whenever but point is after six years
the depreciation is gone tax credits are
exhausted and then that the value of
those panels drops significantly for the
investor or for terraform so then us as
a housing authority can
you know issue additional financing
mechanisms to buy those panels which is
an option to us and then then we would
just own them the ppa would be over
and our existing maintenance staff
hopefully by then would have the skill
set to maintain these panels through the
life of the panels themselves
um a bit more uh
that two and a half megawatts generates
about 3.4 million
kilowatt hours annually which is a
significant portion to give you an idea
dha we use about 24 million kilowatt
hours so we put that to scale
the environmental impact is significant
uh the
predictable energy pricing is great for
dha as well as hud they i mean hud
ultimately
bears the cost for utility bills for
housing authorities in many states
cities and the more hud can get a
reduction or at least a lock and pricing
the more they can plan and
forecast
dha also we did a
program where we
leased the the rooftops and this is kind
of a little different than your typical
ppa your typical ppa your
your third party entity will own the
panels
and the host will buy the electricity
from
the the
owner at a discounted rate so
say if you pay 10 cents a kilowatt hour
maybe the owner pays six cents a
kilowatt hour so so everybody wins it
works out for the investor in a third
party because he's taking the
depreciation the tax credits
so his his performer as well
the site hosts gets a financial
incentive by reducing the cost of energy
which is a another tremendous
benefit for this so that's a traditional
one where the site host is
obligated to buy the electricity from a
discounted rate and and a little spin on
it for our
housing authority is that hud reimburses
us
for all the utilities so whatever we use
in 2014 hud will reimburse us for 2015.
there's a little more complexity around
it than that but ultimately that's how
it works so the idea is that
if we buy at a discounted rate hud saves
a lot of money dha doesn't save much at
all because we just get reimbursed we
use less energy and we or we pay for
less energy therefore hud gives us less
money so to make it incentivize for both
hud and dha we split that incentive so
we suppose you save
you know four cents a kilowatt hour
through the ppa agreement
we
we
had a reduction of two cents for
kilowatt hours and then we leased our
rooftops back for two cents for every
kilowatt hour generated so it's just a
little mechanism for that both hud
benefited and dha so now that hud's
getting a reduction in costs
for utility costs which is terrific
because they
put the bill for housing authorities all
over the country for utility costs so
hud likes it and then dha gets some
revenue from the site leasing agreement
which is
beneficial for us
so that's kind of an overview of our
our system here in our ppa
a quick overview of lessons learned
although there was an upfront cost for
the project itself there was a
significant amount of upgrades that had
to be done to the roofs we replaced a
significant amount of roofs as well as
some structural members below the deck
of the roof so
that costs
we actually
rolled it into the ppa so the the
investor and
infinity at that time said we'll we'll
pay for that cost and we'll just take it
off your roof lease
and you can pay it off slowly so i'm
happy to say that we finally paid that
off which is terrific and the project's
only been completed for about a year and
a half so so we actually that the costs
for all those upgrades were rolled into
the project financing and just we didn't
see our incentive until that was paid
off so it helped out us by not having
upfront costs
another challenge is timely billing and
accurate billing now we have now we buy
power from two different parties we buy
power from our utility company
excel energy and we buy power from
um well now terraform
because they're we're obligated by power
from the panels that are on our roof and
so there's a little complexity behind
just the simplicity of billing periods
you know maybe the utility company
builds billing period between january 1
and
you know january 31st and maybe the
solar company builds between
january 15th and february 14th or
something like so and so to figure out
true consumption within a unit on a
monthly basis is kind of a little
difficult but we're
um our finance department um wasn't they
didn't like me at first but uh or the
project but i think we got it figured
out and um now we can track true
consumption we're working through that
um operations and maintenance damage and
panels it's always an ongoing issue in
terms of you know are the panels
operating as performed if not why is it
something is it a mechanical issue is it
did the resident actually tamper with it
or is it was it vandalized so just the
operations maintenance is continual
again there's a good partnership between
dha
and terraform the site owner as well as
namaste so i think now that we're a year
or two in we're kind of getting the
kinks out of that system and getting
pretty rapid response so if the system's
down we'll find out we'll fix it and
we'll get it back up and running as
quick as possible
and then lastly and just as important as
shading and that goes back to the
insulation with trees
uh you can shade from trees from
structures from your neighboring
structures so there's always
we have to keep a lens out for you know
what do we do if trees grow in 15 years
in shade is it something we can trim
if it's a really old nice looking tree
that adds a lot of aesthetic value to
the property or to the block for that
matter then we probably won't remove it
we'll either
um
we just won't generate as much solar
which we may have to make
a terraform hole for that delta loss or
we can move the panels to a different
rooftop so there's a lot of different
options we have with that but that's
something that we're
continually working on too is making
sure those
panels and the insulation is addressed
and i think that
covers it
is there any questions out there
thanks chris we actually have a bunch of
questions so uh we'll give you a couple
now and then uh move on to the next
presentation and then you know if we
have a bit of room at the end we may add
uh some more questions
so the first one um comes from both paul
and ignacio who are both wondering about
if you could go into a little more
detail about those ongoing costs
maintenance and replacement of
of units um
i guess the question was have you seen
these um
these costs sort of match your
expectations have they been higher or
lower and uh you know what sort of
experience have you had with those
ongoing costs
our experience has been they've met our
expectations and i say that mainly
because
the o m is
a function of the site owner so they
they pay for it they've
budgeted for it in the
project performa
and i um
i'm guessing that if there was an issue
they would we haven't heard anything so
i think
typically what happens is if there's a
system under performing they'll send us
an email i'll dispatch a maintenance
tech to go take a look and it's either
something simple like turn you know a
kid was playing with the inverter
turned it off in that case
our staff will turn it on it's you know
it's a no-brainer no cost
um if it's a tree then dha it's upon us
to either trim it remove it so there is
some cost associated with that it's not
prohibited it typically comes out of the
site each site's maintenance budget
which is we have tree trimming budgeted
every year
um
and then as far if it's not a tree and
it's not a simple shade or a you know
kid turning it off then it's a system
failure which could either be the
inverter or whatever is failing and
those i think over the past two years
we've had maybe two or three of those
and that cost is absorbed by terraform
the pro the site owner and that um i'm
assuming they built in some costs for
that and i haven't heard from them that
it's going over their budget and the
other thing we learned is that
we have the one cost that we
we knew was coming but we didn't really
think about it we weren't sure if
insurance would pay for or not is we had
some large hail storms in denver last
year and the hail storms really damaged
the roofs but the solar panels were fine
because they're they're
extremely strong to hold up the hail but
nonetheless we had to replace the roof
so we had to pull the solar panels down
re-roof it and put the solar panels back
up
so then we asked the insurance so that
cost to pull the solar panels down and
put it back up the de-install and
reinstall is about two to three thousand
dollars of property
and we were
kind of noodle around
to see if our insurance company would
cover that cost and
i don't think we got an answer i think
it by the time we we were afraid it
would just delay the claim so we dha
picked up that cost
but i mean quick answer is
so far it's not been a
huge cost where it's been an issue for
anyone
okay excellent uh okay so the next um
question i've actually had a few
listeners wondering if you go into a
little bit more detail
linda thomas and wyatt about the
financing details of this project there
was some mention of energy bonds
but some of our listeners were wondering
who issued the bonds who purchased them
and who advised on that deal
yeah i can't i think
our partners oak leaf capital handled
the majority of that but i can tell you
that we have a
colorado has an energy office and they
were a part of it
it used to be the governor's enter geo
governor's energy office and who was a
part of that and then they were changing
names and entities the colorado
energy office but they were involved
which is a governor state agency that
helped
package the deal and issue it
oakleaf capital was involved and
unfortunately i think they they did the
majority of that behind the scenes and
so i wasn't 100 privy on all that but i
can certainly get you in connection with
those folks if you want to learn more
detail
i i got on the this the idea was that
the bonds
were the energy bonds they were issued
with a governor's energy office and
hopefully capital is a part of it
and the oak leaf obviously captured or
whoever held the bonds captured the
tax credits and renewable energy credits
and all that
great thanks for that so as i said we've
got a few other questions sort of
pending but we'll hold those
to see if we have any time for them at
the end
so with that i'd like to hand it over to
andy and i think his slides are keyed up
and it should be ready to go
great well good morning and afternoon to
all again and thanks to yale and cdfa
for convening this topic happy to tell
you a little bit more about our role in
expanding access to capital some policy
tie-ins
um
very thematic with the goals of
of what yale and cdfa have put together
and from a slightly different and
complementary perspective from from
chris as good information just provided
a private non-profit economic
development agency we've been around for
about six years and in in every way
possible we're a public and private
partnership so in the direct context of
what we're talking about today we're
focused on raising public capital and
finding other ways to de-risk
private capital to get into the
marketplace
we like perhaps many of you on the phone
in your focused jurisdictions don't want
the advancement of energy markets to be
left out of of greater cincinnati and
northern kentucky and so we're focused
on
making sure that that institutional and
secondary market capital is is coming
here and and we're seeing the cost of
capital come down so more projects can
happen
to date in the first handful years of
our organization we've uh worked in a
little over 3 000 homes and about 175
commercial
buildings both doing assessments and
upgrades and
have managed about 42 million dollars of
projects to date
i'm going to namely highlight two ways
in which we've been focused on expanding
access to capital for energy one on the
residential side i'll just touch on that
briefly on the single family home side
and then secondly on the on the
commercial side so first starting with
gc help
this is an acronym it stands for home
energy loan program
this is a financing structure that we
developed organically
in our marketplace in greater cincinnati
and northern kentucky
we
designed it based loosely four years ago
on
a
underwriting structure that had been
pioneered in pennsylvania through the
pennsylvania treasury
what it culminates into is a 6.9 percent
unsecured residential loan up to 10
years for homeowners to invest
in energy related equipment
the way that comes about though in our
market
unfortunately today you can't walk into
a bank and get it and in fact
in the early conversations we had with
banks and consumer lending
who in theory could look at some modest
precedent a couple of years ago and
and open this up through their own
capital there's a lot of reasons they
didn't
and when they looked at this financing
structure an unsecured equipment loan in
a home
with modest underwriting criteria they
effectively
paralleled it to a jet ski loan
or any other you know
loan like that that is simply an
unsecured equipment loan and so the
response was sure i'll give you capital
but
it looks like a jet ski loan to me and
we've got a jet ski financing product
that's you know
12 or 15 interest rate
uh unsecured and so if if you can take
that then then we'll do it and obviously
that's not going to
change the market that's not going to
expand the access to capital in the
market so that's where we decided that
we
were going to you know raise public
capital and then deploy that public
capital in a way that brings more
private capital into the marketplace
through the creation of a public and
private loan pool
we raised
half a million
when we
kicked this off a little over three
years ago
we backed that half a million of private
capital
with a loan loss reserve
uh pledged by our some public capital
that we raised from the department of
energy
such that we were able to start off with
at that time a million and a half
dollars fund and to this point we lent
out
all of that initially and we're in the
process now of re-lending out dollars
that have been repaid
on the whole with the modest
underwriting criteria you see there a
640 credit score 50 debt to income ratio
uh bankruptcy and foreclosure uh
components tied in there as well
the portfolio has performed very well
we've are conservatively holding a three
percent bad debt reserve on our balance
sheet but in fact uh have seen losses of
far less than one percent uh really two
write-offs in total
less than five thousand dollars in the
first three plus years that the
financing has been around
and so uh the portfolio performance
overall is very strong
we're happy to see that we do know
though that with
um respect to how banks respond to
something like this
three plus years is getting there in
terms of enough history but
uh it's not there yet in fact
we're
mainly focused on seeing this perform
for five or more years before we really
believe that
you know perhaps some local banks will
step into the market will have enough
confidence in this structure and be able
to put their own capital out there
as a non-profit the day that a private
investor puts their own capital out
there for something like this in our
marketplace we will gladly step out of
the market
and look to disrupt something else
you know in other words we're
really wanting to see a pathway toward
private capital and as soon as it's
there uh we'll we'll get out of the
marketplace because that's what
we feel our mission is to do in our in
our region
there's a lot of reasons why this is a
niche
it's certainly a much lower interest
rate than a credit card loan or a jet
ski loan
uh and at the same time we're also
heavily valuing the energy efficiency
criteria
that are designed on the project we're
doing energy assessments in homes and
modeling the financing availability in
part on the energy efficiency savings
that are generated so we're not going to
finance a project that's upside down
in terms of the period
that
the homeowners pay back through energy
savings versus the debt service
i think again too
why are we you know in this market why
isn't the private sector just doing it
on their own
today
these are
what these are some of the steps and the
services if you will that we're
performing
to create the infrastructure and the
market gaps that we believe our market
needs to be able to do more types of
lending like this
first
we know
as perhaps many of you do in your
markets that contractors
that are doing hvac work for homes in 50
or 100 years
aren't going to overnight just
do something different or offer a
different financing program think about
what they do in a different way and so
there's been a very deliberate and
ongoing effort to
recruit contractors for them to sell
financing at the kitchen table with a
homeowner
so we do that aggressively we manage and
track all the work that they're doing
you have chicken and eggs you can't do
any of this work with good contractors
if you don't have proper training so bpi
training and other things have been
offered through a partnership with local
community colleges in southwest ohio and
northern kentucky
we as a third party are reviewing all
projects that come through the energy
underwriting criteria we're doing
third-party on-site verification
after the energy upgrades are done and a
number of other things to add assurance
to the process
we're tracking everything through our
energy modeling software that dumps into
our customer relationship management
tool
like many aspects of our
world these days it's it's all about
data
data informs policy data informs
investing capital data can inform a lot
of things and so we're doing our very
best to manage and track as much data as
possible
we've also offered both sales training
and development of collateral for
contractors again
who
typically haven't been too focused on
the art
and the sciences of
selling financing at the table
staying on theme with our role as a
nonprofit in getting more private
capital to the table i'm going to talk a
little bit about what we're doing along
those lines for pace financing
i don't intend to talk a lot of detail
about pace financing because it's a
topic that
you know has i'm sure continue to
be a topic of interest and focus for for
cdfa and yale i'm certainly happy to
field more questions but i'll go through
some of the pace
uh details pretty quickly and focus
really in on the theme of this webinar
uh in a couple of slides here
but fundamentally pace is a financing
tool that
brings capital
through special assessments for
energy efficiency and renewable energy
for any
non-residential building in ohio and
kentucky
there are a few states like california
and florida that are looking at and and
are far advanced on the residential side
but for the context of our conversation
today regarding pace i am referring
exclusively to the non-residential
market
it's a national market that's growing by
the day pace now the national trade
association for pace programs have done
a great job tracking this data many of
you have maybe seen this data before
i think the point is that it's the
market's transforming
every day
and some of these states on here that
are white
or
are light blue are now dark blue where
there's
active pace programs and
past legislation uh just very recently
even already a couple of new states
uh in this market
with successful legislative efforts this
year alone
so the market's big and it's growing and
a billion dollar market
which is roughly what this market has
been sized at
is enough to say again
back to in our case greater cincinnati
northern kentucky what are we doing
to make sure that a billion dollar
market that's going to continue to grow
doesn't pass us over
and there's things that have to be done
that the private sector can't do on
their own
to make sure that happens and so
um
we've talked really about the
applicability of pace to a lot of
different uh building type types so i'll
jump ahead and just highlight the
uh some of the advantages
and why we think that in our market
unlike a handful of markets across the
country it
works really well
there's a list of solutions down the
right hand column here and what you see
is a lot of reasons why uh pace is is
supreme
uh or or better than a traditional bank
loan the transferability to new
ownership the transferability of
payments to tenants
based on most lease structures there's a
lot of benefits there that we're really
trying to harness and even in some cases
an ability to treat pace financing as an
off-balance sheet item
cdfa and others spend a lot of time on
the development finance side of things
and so there's a lot of reasons why we
think the pace is a great development
finance tool again back to our theme
today bringing more access to capital
namely the second bullet down here
highlighting the fact that private bond
investors in pace are willing to go up
to 90 percent
assessment plus loan to value so if you
have a 70 percent
mortgage on a property they're going to
give you another 20 percent
uh they are coming in senior but they're
going to give you another 20 access to
capital through to pace and and so that
is
uh without question a way to be able to
bring more capital to a particular
building that may otherwise be
constrained given the security uh and
the senior lien status that pace in
commercial buildings can offer
an owner guarantee is often not required
so again if that's a hold up if there
are other issues a particular owner has
that is not a prohibition in being able
to access pace capital
it can cover a lot of different measures
in most states this is true where it's
going to cover most everything on the
mechanical electrical and plumbing scope
which includes things like grooves
elevators and solar as well
and so it's
increasingly uh able to
not only cover a large portion of the
capital stack but more and more banks
are warming up to it and in fact over 75
banks have signed off on pace
assessments as senior leads and that
says that
it's a market
a tool that is
increasing in awareness and acceptance
which is good for all of us
but when i get back to our role as a
non-profit i want to highlight a couple
of these things where
something like pace although it's easy
to go through a couple of these slides
does not happen on its own and is
at least today administratively
burdensome and so we're focused as a
non-profit on providing that
administration
in a turnkey way and at scale
versus expecting every local government
to be able to provide it on their own to
create a district that
allows a building owner to assess
themselves and increase in taxes
to repay bond capital there's a lot of
steps in the middle there that that
often get left out and we are focused on
on resolving those at scale and so
we're actively again like i said on the
residential loan program side we're very
active in recruiting contractors
we have to build interest and build
demand if we're going to get private
capital investors private bond investors
to the marketplace it's a lot of chicken
and egg and so we've got to move both
things long in parallel tracks
we are also applying our own financial
expertise and actually doing some of the
early stages of energy underwriting so
that when deals from cincinnati go out
to the private pace bond market uh
they're they're much more advanced and
there's much less
uh
fallout in terms of
how much detail
the
private bond investors are seeing with
respect to a project so we're able to
do a lot more vetting that makes the
process for private
investors more efficient
one gap two that many markets have seen
and and some markets have designed
solutions for uh as we are is
you know it's great to get a private
pace deal out to the bond market and if
it's a two or three million dollar
size project there's probably not an
issue in that size project getting out
the bond market but what if it's a
quarter million or half a million dollar
uh
pace project it's got all the good
energy underwriting criteria but it's
not
large enough to cost effectively
be able to
go out to the market by itself
the creation of a local
line of credit or bridge revolving loan
fund is one way to overcome
that hurdle that fund lends immediately
holds the
pace assessment up until you build up
two or three million dollars worth of
projects and then you're able to uh
issue a bond the bond proceeds pay back
that fund and that fund is reinvested
back for that same purpose so again
we've designed a public and private
financing structure for for both
local governments state governments and
banks and private investors to invest
into this fund and we can lend that
capital out
on a bridge a basis for small deals
to get them
capital when they need it and ultimately
get out to market
so again the focus at the end of the day
for the type of work that we do is
developing conformity and scale
to bring private pace investors to ohio
and to kentucky and let me for one
second highlight the kentucky piece
because just two weeks ago we were
successful in
working with a team
in kentucky to pass
enabling legislation for pace and i can
tell you back to the theme of our
conversation and webinar today that if
there was not as much data out there as
there is both in other markets and data
we've created in ohio that was shared to
decision makers in kentucky
there's no way that kentucky decision
makers would have been comfortable
enabling this kind of legislation
there was extensive vetting
extensive questions and extensive
concerns that were raised throughout the
process but by virtue of there being
data
and precedent in other states and
private market activity at the level
that there is
we were ultimately
successful in getting kentucky decision
makers to feel confident it was the
right thing to do to now open up
kentucky
to the billion dollar market that is
that is pace so
we're focused on you know kind of both
sides of the river of the ohio river in
our jurisdiction and making sure that
private capital is accessible on a
commercial scale
for energy efficiency and renewable
energy projects
that
concludes my presentation i look forward
to questions
great thanks so much andy um so i am
cognizant of the fact that chris has a
hard stop um at two and there are a few
uh questions that we did
that were postponed to him so we'll put
one question to him and then we'll shift
things back to uh
back to andy that's not too confusing
for everyone
um so it was a question chris from from
actually someone else called chris uh
about your
2.5 megawatt project um and about a ppa
uh so first of all is that
covered by a single ppa
and can you talk a little bit about the
process if so of tying multiple sites
into a single ppa
um and then also a little bit about the
um the sort of um
price in terms of you know cents per
kilowatt hour that you're able to uh to
achieve and the sort of target uh price
that makes a ppa like that actually
pencil out
yeah so
as i mentioned the typical ppa is not a
bunch of little sites just one or two
big solar fields or farms this in fact
is
666 different meters which is production
meters which measures the amount of
solar
so it definitely takes a lot more lag
work a lot more design
but ultimately all the so each meter has
a production meter which we know how
many kilowatt hours we generate
and that um all those combined so every
month we get bills from each of those
and that's how we we time all together
so again with the financing and the
project development
it was
fo it was mirrored after a typical ppa
but the only difference was there's a
lot a lot of different little sites
but everything kind of wraps up into the
same two and a half megawatt about 10
million dollars of investment the same
contract the same lease
site lease purchase agreement or
excuse me not least purchase but the
roof lease agreement between us and the
owner is the same so it's all
all round up into one project
and then as far as the
the rates
depending on what properties we're at we
have different rates whether they're
commercial residential and different
tiers as well
but typically you know around denver we
get about 11 cents a kilowatt hour
um and we we gave like i said we split
the incentive between us and hud so
we generate um revenue from the roof
lease agreement and then
we also get a discounted rate which gets
past the hut so the discount is about
one cent per kilowatt hour for us
um in the kilowatt hour tariff for us is
between 10 and 12 depending on where
you're at but
so that that that one cent goes to hud
and then dha has the site lease
agreement we get the the rest of it
um rush that benefit through the lease
agreement
and depending on i i
i'm not sure if any of you can answer
this too i that delta of
how how this works in terms of what
what's the discount for the electric
rate you need to make it all work i i
think it depends on
each state and each
investor's tax appetite and all that
like it could be four cents it could be
six cents could be two cents but i think
it's a moving target depending on each
project deal
okay great um so next we've got a few
questions for andy uh first we've
actually had a few listeners uh paul
charlie and uh wyatt who were all
wondering um about the source of the
private capital for the gc home energy
loan program
where that was sourced from how you went
about raising it and how sustainable
this source of funds is as the program
grows and reaches greater adoption rates
yes good question
the source of capital three plus years
ago for that program was the greater
cincinnati foundation which is our
family foundation
in in cincinnati and
that's an impact investment for them so
the way that they look at that is
actually uh a divestment of their mutual
funds and some of the other things that
that sit in their endowment and and a
way for them to invest capital with a
return
expectation but in a below market return
with
the i as well on the creation of
social impact that meets their criteria
so they have been a funding partner to
us in the past and now they're also an
investment partner
that sort of capital is far from
limitless
but they continue as many foundations
actually are at a at a local and
national basis uh
to uh invest more cap more of their
capital into this strategy so
the impact investment
marketplace as many of you may know on
the phone uh itself is is growing
significantly um
seeing there to be you know good
economic ways of solving social problems
and certainly uh i think
you know
uh macarthur foundation
rockefeller brothers fund and some
others are among the more prominent
across the country
and
certainly we've been happy with the
local partnership we have with them we
also
see it as a means of being able to raise
additional public capital at a at a at a
zero or certainly a below market return
expectation and when i say below market
i'm typically referring to something
less than
uh something around three percent
now the one thing that i also forgot to
highlight in terms of sustainable
sources of capital
and
and i'm sorry that i forgot to highlight
this because it's a big deal
uh is
is that this is now
from a secondary market financing
standpoint not just a local program in
cincinnati or a local program in
pennsylvania it's in fact
um
underwriting standards that that we
adopted are now in fact part of
wheel which is a national financing
instrument it's an acronym that stands
for warehouse for energy efficiency
lending and this was at the bottom of
one of my slides
but the first wheel secondary market
transaction using the conforming
standards that
we created amongst places in kentucky
and pennsylvania and others are going to
actually be part of the first secondary
market transaction where citigroup is
coming in and providing institutional
capital
so to the point of the question now
that there's been precedent not only in
cincinnati but in a few other states
adopting these similar standards there
is a source of
institutional capital the cost of that
capital is coming in at around nine
percent that's not the cost yet that
everybody wants to see
but it's a reduction of cost of what was
previously about 16 percent
on the institutional capital side
through a
financing program that fannie and
freddie had offered previously and so
we're going from 16 to nine and
hopefully you know those that are on
this team of structuring this deal afc
first and pennsylvania and the
pennsylvania treasury along with
renewable funding
and others are
are optimistic that the institutional
source of cost of capital can get down
to about seven percent so it's getting
there and it's taking a big step here in
the next few weeks when this first
institutional deal closes
great okay we have another uh good
question from heather um
other than pace do you see a trend in do
you see another trend in commercial
finance the smaller projects in the sort
of fifty thousand to one million dollar
range
and as you stated in your discussion
about residential do you find that
commercial contractors need finance
training as well
the i'll start with the second question
and say yes i think particularly i think
what we've seen and i i don't think this
is unique to cincinnati by any stress
but what we've seen is a is a pretty big
gap
in financing in the
small to medium-sized market so really
any energy project less than three
million dollars to a non-investment
grade
uh
client uh because if it's investment
grade and it's over three million
dollars that's where
other types of bonds that's where
performance contracts and other things
have come in that has typically
provided at least a little bit more
ready access to capital
um
so we believe at scale for our market
pace is that
first big focus of ours in really
resolving some of those gaps
um
what other tools that are out there to
resolve some of those gaps as well i
think particularly perhaps for the 13 or
14 states that don't have pace in place
um it's tough i i don't i'm not aware of
anything that's that's really at scale
that doesn't mean by any stretch that
there's not i know some some boutique
financing firms have some
some pretty unique you know kind of
solar tax equity structures and some
other things that work in some states
um
but um
but beyond our focus for pace and that
small to
medium-sized uh
prod you know project size
i don't have a i don't have a great
answer for for what the other solutions
are out there i think i think those that
are out there are either unique to a
particular jurisdiction
and or a particular financial provider
and not necessarily part of a a quote
unquote national
tool or national market movement
great well on the topic of pace and how
you sort of continue to grow that
there's a question from uh
bahara
who was asking about the interaction and
the nature relationships between local
government and gc in the context of
cpace how easy it was to bring local
governments on board
and how that how that relationship
tended to work
yeah i mean i think the biggest thing we
find for local governments is that
why are we here you know what is what is
the energy alliance and non-profit doing
and
for a local government what we're
effectively doing for them is providing
them an economic development service
at no cost
and in fact doing something in
for them that would otherwise cost them
to do
on their own but doing it in a
consistent consistent and conforming way
for the benefit of a broader regional
financing tool
so when we can basically go in and say
we want to do something for you for free
you just have to accept this tool as as
a viable financing tool in your
marketplace pass legislation that gives
us an ability to connect a private
building owner with private capital
there's no hard city dollars that need
to pass through um
you're serving as a conduit and letting
us do all the administrative work so i
think when we boil it down to
um you know
us providing a free economic development
service for a local government that
connects private capital to a private
building
we typically find a good response not a
hundred percent by any stretch but uh
but but typically it's not a pretty good
response
great so we're almost out of time but uh
one final question
which was about the technical
underwriting for the gc pace program
did you develop your own internal staff
expertise or did you outsource that
technical underwriting
we
do a little bit of both and by that i
mean that we know
in our conversations with private bon
baseball investors we know what they're
looking for
um we know they're we have a good sense
for their underwriting criteria and that
gives us a chance to
make sure that we're collecting that
data
on a
potential project that comes through the
cincinnati region we can package it up
and send that financial package off to
that
private bond investor so it it creates
this role that we call a value-added
conduit
we're certainly not a broker we don't
want to be a broker a broker gets us
into all kinds of securities laws and
other things that we don't want to and
don't need to touch but
we can be a robust matchmaker and that's
the role that we've served formally to
date now at the end of the day um the
particular private bond investor whoever
it is like structured finance associates
or clean fund or some of these others
that um that perhaps folks on the phone
have heard about that are more
nationally prominent
even over wells fargo or hannah
armstrong they certainly have their own
underwriters on staff that will you know
thoroughly vet the project
but we're going to help make sure that
they don't see a project that's already
underwater so by by our internal
kind of first pass of underwriting we're
looking for any big glaring issues
uh so that the private bond investors
don't have to invest their time
uh into seeing something that wouldn't
work
however from a formal
underwriting and final stamp it's
certainly incumbent upon the
private investor to apply their own
scrutiny criteria
great well uh we are out of time um
so i would like to uh thank chris and
andy for a couple of fantastic uh
presentations
along with jason and the team at the
cdfa for really making this a great
webinar
uh i'd like to thank all of our
listeners um we had a ton of excellent
questions and uh we simply ran out of
time to
put all of them to the to the presenters
but the contact details of chris and
andy are in the presentation which you
can download in the go to meeting
webinar window
so if you know if you have anything that
you'd like to follow up with them please
feel free to reach out
i'd like to remind everyone that a
recording for today's talk will be made
available through the yale center for
business and the environment website
and i'd like to also remind everyone to
keep an eye out for the next webinar
in this series which will be scheduled
for may 5th
so this is michael pluckett from the
yale center for business and the
environment saying so long from new
haven connecticut